voilà une arrestation bonne et due forme
un bloc à l'avant bras
c'est bloqué c'est bien bloqué là que tu
aimais trade avant tout par une fille
cool et j'ai dans qu'est ce que tu
attends quoi tomber une banque était
sérieuse ou quoi non mais j'y glisse est
là
[Musique]
et enfin les gens de la cantine une
réponse me contre et gramat le gars a
souffert il avait importe quoi un mec
qu'est ce qui n'a fait oui daniel bahr
il a fait le mur du son la fnh peuvent
maintenant donc ça permet donc et
parfois ça c'est vrai que wild
[Musique]
sauf que là j'ai cerné son plan
c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'on va le prendre à son
propre jeu c'est à dire te le dire non
mais des fois je vous rends pas compte
tellement à fond de tech pour faire bon
poids de prendre à son propre jeu serait
six mois
[Musique]
où
non
ok c'est à dire
à quatre bras
hamada
c'est rien ça
[Applaudissements]
tiens c'est sérieux mais [ __ ] je suis
cardiaque fin du mois [ __ ] je passe au
dessus
dit on est obligé d'aller dans un trou
paumé comme ça et on dira décor de film
ben voila je le sentais ya pas de réseau
open web 0 bord j'ai fait une petite
angoisse mais ça va mieux ça dit qu'elle
j'ai tout pour l'angoissé
je passe un casting pour un film à
hollywood mec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'est pas tout seul j'ai vu qu'il
avait des grosses cordes
des grands yeux
est ce que quelqu un mouchoir ta gueule
à la montre et moi votre côté pienaar
[Musique]
alors quelle est la cible mammifères ou
être humain la pire soirée de tout même
bon
où la tempête un trader
coupez wahaha bravo à toute l'équipe
c'était super mais pas de monstre
c'était une mise en scène fait j'ai fait
un casting est pas longtemps j'ai peur
mais c'était
pas [ __ ] tu m'as tout quel bar tu
parles